you've had quite an amazing amazing
career let's talk first about the news
at hand Celebrity Apprentice Donald
Trump firing you last night what
happened well it's not the first time
I've been fired so but I he fired me
probably the easiest of all of them but
uh again it was a fun experience I
appreciate the opportunity to know that
he and NBC gave me but uh it was a great
time there I mean I learned a lot got to
know a lot of my cast and with that
particular task that I got fired for it
was a fundraising task and some of my
resources didn't follow through for me
so that was it was heartbreaking to say
the least well switching to a lot of the
news that's been coming out of your
league as of late the NFL announced that
they'd finished their investigation to
the Ray Rice issue and have determined
that the league in Roger Goodell did not
and did that they hadn't seen that tape
before the public had what's been your
sort of overall reaction to how all of
this is unfolded do you think that that
they've missed the boat in some ways in
terms of the opportunity that they had
to get out in front of the issue what's
your sense of how they've handled it
well I think it's unfortunate for for
the black guy that the NFL has taken
this year I mean I think they're taking
the necessary steps obviously to correct
the mistakes that they've made I think
that's unfortunate for office for Ray
Rice I think he got a situation where he
got penalized twice for the same
incident so a little bit of double
jeopardy fixing it for him no I mean
when you look at that tape well I mean
if they see what happened I mean I just
I don't know how yeah I'm not condoning
what he did I think you know he I'm
talking about in terms of the rift of
the punishment that he received I think
he they reviewed the information that
they had been given in terms of the NFL
Roger Goodell they punished him for that
and he should have been punished as he
as he did get it out of the way you know
absolutely right off the bat what so in
some ways they missed an opportunity
because they could have dealt with it
initially absolutely that's what I was
four
yes um does the NFL have an image
problem at this point um they do I mean
it's definitely evident with all the
things that are going on and I think
it's not only the NFL's issue that needs
to be you know needs to be addressed but
I think the players themselves they need
to address themselves as far as how they
carry out and in terms of their condo
yeah you know that it's it's not just
the Ray Rice issue of course it's um
Adrian Peterson but um you know just how
women also are sort of a reflected on
within the league I mean I think this
has been a big issue overall um and and
something that you know the NFL probably
needs to get out in front of especially
when you consider such a large female
fan base absolutely again it's one of
those things that men in general I think
it starts at the home we now obviously
need to cherish our women obviously Alex
that I don't condone any of the things
that have been happening throughout this
league and it needs to be better turning
to another issue that's plaguing the NFL
head injuries uh are they are they doing
enough to protect players here what more
needs to be done to ensure that you know
people are not hurt on the field and you
know suffering the consequences frankly
for the rest of their life in some cases
with these concussions right I think
with the safety issues obviously they're
doing things in terms of the equipment
they're doing all that they can I think
obviously with some of the rules that
they put in place to allow players in
terms like receivers running backs and
obviously the defensive defensive guys
they're the ones that are really
suffering you know from a standpoint of
they've been taught for so long to hit a
certain way and so now they're trying to
address that with obviously the way you
know we tackle and you know obviously
they protecting the quarterbacks who are
the faces of the organization and the
league so they're doing the necessary
things this is it's not an overnight
process and it's going to take a little
time but i think you know overall
they're they're doing what they need to
is
is theirs baby steps but they're
obviously those steps needs to be a
little expedite